hey guys Ryan Roy Roy Roy Roy right here
and Jerry arery
we don't watch the Assassin's Creed
unity presents Rob Zombie's French
Revolution now I know there's a lot of
Assassin's Creed videos that a lot of
you guys have been saying I should check
out there's a lot it's a [ __ ] mana so
[ __ ] lot mate we're gonna get around
to all them but right now we're starting
off with a Rob Zombie's French
Revolution and North America thing would
you guys mind I know about us is that we
especially him though our big fans of
the zombie big big zombie have been
doing a few Michonne and we got insane
because of his films actually yeah like
Devil's Rejects like I was so impressed
with that we'll read this it's like a
committed [ __ ] film to what that was
yes and I really enjoyed it and even
like I really don't give two shits where
critics say even if I don't really care
for the movie like when you look at his
what he's going for and you see that
he's pretty committed to what he's going
for you know I always committed yeah
he's always very committed like in
Halloween too like that just like broke
the mold all [ __ ] Michael Myers
movies yeah that's a better dark that
was like a really bold thing to do I
hated it the first time I saw I walked
out of the fear but the second time I
saw it I was like kind of like something
bad I have no idea what's of all the
arrow if it's a song or movie but I
think it's like a short it's him doing
something different
a desperate people know nothing of mercy
for years we the people had suffered
County of mental fed to starve to rested
to care but no more
oh cool la république iDEN dude the
years of war and failed military
campaigns a playful power by Kings who
cared more for their legacy than their
people with a nation deeply in debt the
nobility carried on with the lavish
lifestyles ignoring our struggles and
letting taxes upon us to shoulder the
load we starved in the streets tossed
aside like a rats no longer would we be
left to die
we formed a National Assembly for the
Third Estate our first step in the fight
for independence
yet we never could have known the
dangers that lie waiting the National
Assembly vowed for life we were willing
to do what was needed violently if
necessary surged unstoppable the taste
of freedom and liberty fellow finish of
our lives war busty fell we grew
hungrier not read of a brain but for
justice Oh
even his highness wasn't safe from our
reach for too long Gotti dismissed our
frets let him try to ignore us now
posture ordering the death of the king
one month Oersted for control he claimed
to represent the people against the
monarchy but was far more dangerous than
any king maximilien de Robespierre the
slightest suspicion of
counter-revolution was met with death
for mere rumors and speculations
many of us meet our end families torn
apart by Orbis peers rain a reign of
terror hundreds of thousands dead
straight son mad with blood but the
reign of terror would not last all this
pierre knew he was to meet the very end
he had bought upon so many while
fighting his rest inside to make his
escape but he was unsuccessful I'll pull
it to the Joe to remind him of his
failure
a desperate people know nothing of mercy
-
this is the history you know behind the
bloodshed blanketing a different secret
revolution awaited its story burning to
be told
make history [ __ ] that's pretty awesome
that's pretty rad the animation was
really cool yeah you know it's
heightened but that's you know a neat
little history lesson right there that's
hiding but it's like intriguing to pay
attention to and then like it's a good
tease to be like well I really like
these games incorporate history and
stuff like that because I mean you know
we've read about those people in school
I wish I paid I wish I chained more of
that reading but ya don't wash it of it
there are some really bloody battles
especially in French history did they
really put head some sick I imagine at
some point how cool we don't do that
anymore
yeah I think it's probably for the
better really I would love to win a war
like that
ah this is the head statement yeah it is
is head on a pike if I was to be in a
war I'd be that guy in the battlefield
where people build what are you doing
we're leaving
I'm putting heads on the sticks so a
waste of time
like you're dulling a good knife you're
gonna need that for later and now it's a
completely useless beer under their
heads I've been chomped oh yeah what is
the point it's a lot harder to chop off
a head than you think this I'm just
gonna camp out here for the night I'll
catch up with you guys in the morgue
yeah I got I gotta go we got some work
to do I'm trying to make a point for
when people come by yeah anyway yeah
that's all I got from the trailer it's
just a little short about history but
it's I know it's really cool it's a very
visual guy and I think it's actually
think it's neat to see him working in
this kind of animation know that fits
his style perfectly yeah it's like it's
like everything we talked about like
it's it's heightened like it's it's
always heightened in some way it fits
perfectly for like a comic book looking
kind of world you know yeah now I'm
sitting here going
zombie presents the French Revolution
yeah I'll be pretty [ __ ] cold yeah it
seemed like you really knew how to do it
then it seemed like a bunch of southern
people yelling at each other you know is
your goal in French be good okay I
really do want to play this game I did
too I I played one of the Assassin's
Creed games it was really awesome
they're teasing the hell out of this
game if you use channel you can
subscribe right here it's awesome
there's cool stuff on there yadda yadda
yadda you know what I mean
JD Holloman he said hey Ryan can I get a
shout out please that will make my
summer break Dan that's like three
months worth of time you're making that
I know he's doing a happen if depressing
is unreal is good yeah well you know
maybe don't let G Z doesn't know anybody
my shout out is gonna make your summer
break jail [ __ ] me your dick
wholesome JD Holloman what are you doing
with your life JD is everything okay
masking disgust I care about you but JD
you know what take it all back I'm glad
this makes your summer break its honor
you know it's pretty [ __ ] sweet I
mean it kind of makes sense like when
you think about me and then I give you a
shout-out like the person of my status
who's giving you a shout-out
we passed 20,000 subscribers we did man
we are super famous in YouTube world
right now
look out PewDiePie here we go here we go
put your head on a stick I get it
PewDiePie I will not do that oh gee um
if you betray me I'll put your head on a
stick you got it kid pay king beastly
and beastly give me a shout-out
I know Ziggy or better known as the hopf
vid 3 to 2 yeah he's a gay boy my name
is king beets Lee that's also my ps4
name what is this comment I don't get
the comment at all zu z ze uh another
subscriber Ziggy Marley Ziggy Stardust
yeah Ziggy
getting Ziggy with it don't sequel to
getting jiggy with it Dolph Ziggler
I don't know but King Beasley I think he
wants a shout out if you're a ps4 online
and play with King Beasley yeah I guess
he wants to super motors online gaming
I'd like to get a ps4 someday I love to
get a ps4 it's super wicked that they
don't cost six hundred dollars now it's
funny how video games we don't need to
play and we really don't yeah we could
do without them and if we want to play
it we could just wait a while while it
drops down in price the only reason we
don't is because everyone else is
already talking about yeah and you feel
left out of the conversation you're like
wait I should want that too yeah so I'm
gonna spend a lot more money and time on
this um anyway ziggy-zag a boy though
good for him I I'm glad he's embracing
his life yeah yeah that's awesome
like good that is easy especially it's
such a young age Ziggy if you're out
there
go ahead suck some dicks and [ __ ] keep
on being you right back in the ass or
you [ __ ] keep only ass doesn't matter
just do it enjoy yourself King be sleaze
a meanie I can't tell but it does seem
aggressive it does seem aggressive yeah
dissing regressive I like aggressive
actually maybe you're gay
mmm confusing the whole audience right
now that's what I'm doing you can tiger
sound want to throw it off you know what
I mean like I'm like oh my guys right
and gay like people gonna forget yeah so
it's like a big [ __ ] deal what
someone's gay apparently and now today
oh my god what well it's the celebrities
gate holy [ __ ] did you hear what this
guy sexual preferences we make a big
deal out of stuff that it doesn't really
affect anybody that's gonna change the
way I view that guy as an actor now none
of these people are assassins but we
believe in when they are none of these
people are superheroes but we believe it
when they are so so when you were under
the impression they were straight you
could believe it that yeah like I don't
understand mr. nerd strike Ryan and
Jerry my name is Wesley such a huge fan
please please please please give me a
shoot out when a shout-out when I went
to see guardians Agassi I saw Jerry
because he was asking for a poster but
can only get it
if you went to see it in IMAX Rudy I was
gonna say hi but I was almost late so
yeah so please shout out oh dude oh man
saw you cool that's strange well like
right now I'm thinking back I'm like
somebody knew who I was at a place now
where it was like a few days ago oh
that's cool it was cool you should get a
set hide you good to hear from you now
you should have said hot you would have
taken a photo with you on his camera I
probably would I mean I would have - no
one want to be a jerk when I met Carlos
first person to recognize me never
forgetting that guy's name yeah when I
make Carlos first person to recognize me
as if I've been recognized multiple
times
well guys um mr. nerd strike you should
have said hi you dumb son of a [ __ ]
next time hello now I know the other guy
[ __ ] you Lizzie burgesses he/she wants
Erica Burgess whatever I don't know she
I think she's you okay it's just [ __ ]
yeah she not dude she wants your penis
in her mouth right now
Lizzie message him your phone number at
the real rejects YouTube page watching
my show up hey you got something better
today that would be I don't know how to
process that that's very strange
maybe blushing eggs well it's just like
it is a bit surreal what I can you're
blushing homo what the [ __ ] is the
matter with you it's it's a little
surreal it's like it's not the kind of
thing that you're normally prepped to
expect out of life so Liam somebody who
you've never met or seen before has an
opinion about you it's always like whoa
I dude it's awesome to see that awesome
I slightly jealous cuz not one girl out
there has done that for me are you sure
I'm sure I'm sure I read all of these
comments I got I can't I don't believe
for some reason I don't not believe you
but I also don't believe you no not one
girl's know that you know I talked about
her maybe you just haven't picked up the
signal you're right I have misread a lot
of these straightforward comments well
we covered a lot of topics today guys so
why not end this on a question for you
guys yeah
pretty hello which is perfect right now
why can you just come here for a moment
gosh hey guys like ours oh hey she's uh
my Persian friend and I'm ready for this
I know she just showed up we're about to
turn the cameras off we'll see what
happens next
right nothing's gonna write nice things
are gonna Ryan right is wrong right now
no no such thing in my vocabulary we're
gonna ask a question so there's a
question I want to ask the audience what
question do you think it should be give
me anything okay thank you can come with
any question like yeah go for it would
you rather have sex with a monkey or a
dead person that is a great question
that is a great question miss what are
you talking about have sex with a monkey
or deaf pursue her thank you encouraging
this honestly I'd go with the monkey but
a dead person is still a person but his
dick is deceased oh yeah can't even get
hard yeah so wish you'll remember one of
your scenario because because it's not
possible so you'd rather [ __ ] the monkey